hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google I work on
graphics and animations and today I
wanted to talk a little bit about window
animations in another show that we did
we saw a little bit about view
animations which are the animation API
is that you can use for releases prior
to 3.0 there's a more complete animation
system starting with 3.0 but if you're
doing window animations you still want
to use the animation resource files of
the older API so we'll see how to use
those today to get to grinds kinds of
transitions between activities and sub
activities in your activity so let's
take a look at a demo I call this demo
window animations and you'll see a few
buttons and then a little bit map down
at the bottom and each of the buttons
enables a different type of window
transition as it goes between the main
activity and the sub activity so default
animations you just get whatever the
system provides you which is the the
scale fade at least on the current
platform it's the scale fader activity
so we scale and fade and we scale and
fade out that's the default you can do
translate animations so you can provide
a custom animation of any type that you
specify using the view animation system
in this case we're going to slide things
in and out so the translate animations
slides in the new activity slides out
the old activity and then when you back
out we get sort of the reverse thing
which is actually a separate animation
as we'll see in the code in a minute
scale animations is a new capability
that came online in jelly bean where you
can actually specify a sub rectangle to
launch the new activity from and it'll
scale up from that point so it'll start
out at the the view the the visuals that
it's going to have when it's running in
the fullscreen and then it'll simply
scale that up over time so scale
animation launches that window from the
location that I gave it which is
relative to that button that we clicked
on now you'll notice that although we
scale into the activity there we still
get some defaults or non scaling
animations when we back out of it and
this is a limitation the current system
where we can't scale back out of it
instead we can just use the the prior
way of you know translation or
scale fate or whatever other kind of
animation that you want and then finally
we have the bitmap at the bottom which
is another variation of the scale
animation we can we can specify not only
the sub rectangle the scale from but
also the bitmap to start from in this
case I took a screenshot of what the
activity was going to look like and I
saved it a smaller size and we're simply
going to scale up from that one into the
larger one so we can see that we get
exactly the same kind of view scaling up
into the larger activity now what that's
hiding is that we're actually cross
fading from one representation to the
other so it starts out at the smaller
bitmap and then as it scales up it also
cross fades to the fullscreen
representation of the sub activity so
that's the demo but the more interesting
part is the actual code how does this
stuff work so we can take a look at this
class I've defined called window
animations and in here we have the
buttons that we saw on the screen and
then we have an image view that holds
that bitmap and as you click on each of
the buttons you get a different kind of
effect depending on what we were trying
to do with window animations the default
button just uses the system behavior so
when you click on that it launches this
sub activity let's take a quick look at
sub activity not much going on there
it's just a sub activity it only exists
to provide something for us to look at
when we transition to the sub activity
all right so all it does is launch the
sub activity and then the system itself
just takes care of doing the translation
the default scale fade transition that
it normally has the translate button the
second button down did a custom
animation where we slid the new activity
and slid the old activity out and then
on the way back out we slid to the right
instead sort of a nice reversing
behavior gets kind of an indication of
the flow of the application in and out
of the sub activity so here we launched
a different sub activity which we call
animated sub activity and I'll show you
in a second why we were using not just
the regular sub activity and then we
created a bundle and activity options
bundle and said okay well here's this
custom animation that we're creating and
we're going to load in a couple of
resources here so we can take a look at
those in our resources folder in the
Anam directory we have a slide in left
resource which is a translate animation
that's going to slide in and have the
duration
capabilities specified in it so we're
going to start at from X Delta so we're
basically getting to start off the
screen on a percent of the width of my
parent and then we're going to slide
into an X Delta zero so we're going to
start out there and then slide in over a
duration of 500 milliseconds go back we
can take away the other animation we're
specifying so that was for the new
activity coming in and then slide out
left was for the activity going out
slide out left we can see here and then
this one starts from an X Delta zero so
basically where that activity is now and
it's going to slide out to half the
width of the parent out over 500
milliseconds so it'd be sort of a
parallax effect they're actually going
at a different rate it's not just moving
together in lockstep but instead one is
moving in faster than the other is going
out kind of a nice effect there now the
reason we had an animated sub activity
there is because the transitions that we
specify here for the window animations
only control what happens when we go
into the sub activity but what if we
actually want to have a custom
transition coming back out of that
activity as well well for that we need a
little bit of code in the sub activity
so instead of using the normal subject
if 'ti with no behavior specified in we
have this animated sub activity and here
we override the finish method call super
and then override pending transition
then we specify different transitions
which we don't need to go in and look at
the code it's fairly straightforward
basically we're sliding the sub activity
out to the right and then sliding the
the main activity in to the right as
well sort of the reverse from the
transition we did to begin with okay so
now we can go back and look at the
original code and see the more
interesting stuff what's going on with
those thumbnail scaling animations
instead again we use activity options
this is the one where we scaled up from
the button itself and we basically give
it the rectangle that it's going to
scale from but for the content that it's
actually going to scale on the screen it
uses the content of the full screen
activity itself so we don't need to
specify anything else there we just say
where do you start from and how large
are you and then it takes care of all
the rest of scaling that thing in
overtime and finally on the last one
when we're actually scaling in from a
thumbnail we not only give it the
location that is going to scale from but
we also give it the bitmap that it's
going to use so it's going to start with
that rep
and then scale-up and fade into
crossfade into the the full screen
activity that you're going into so here
we create this bitmap we're actually
just loading a bitmap this is the
screenshot that I took earlier and saved
as a drawable and then we create some
activity options with the appropriate
parameters and start the activity and
then the window animation just uses that
bundle to run the appropriate animation
so these are window animations they're
useful for giving a custom look to your
app application your activities it's
important to point out that you can do
this for sub activities it's a little
trickier to do it for main activities
and the general advice is don't it's
kind of nice for the users to have a
consistent experience across the device
as they're using the main UI and part of
that is getting consistent transition
behaviors as they launch activities now
once they're in your activity that's
custom experience that's that's totally
understandable how you might want to
customize that according to what your
application needs to do but as far as
going between activities are just
launching it from the launcher screen
it's kind of nice to let the the default
system behavior still stay intact and
use the custom window animations for the
activity transitions actually within
your activities thanks for tuning in